so I don't know call karen has ice
bucket challenge me and while I'm fairly
sure that anyone is going direct to a
iced which is mounting your own disease
of rough translation in the UK art has
already donated well it would be rude to
refuse only I think I'd teach something
as well so I have not a bucket but a
bathtub full of very cold ice water and
a heart rate monitor which is currently
showing 112 pics I'll be honest I'm not
look forward to this they expect that
didn't go to nice water on Technic
specifically on your face would start a
fight or flight response an adrenaline
response but that's not the case what it
does is activate something called
mammalian diving reflex something that
most mammals have to one extent or
another and humans still have thanks for
work of evolution being held over
millions and millions of years give that
cold water in your face
what happens if your heart rate goes
down seriously
blood gets pulled in from all your
extremities just to keep the heart and
the brain alive and working because well
going brain knows you might have to be
there for a very long time so 108 let's
see wow that incredibly unpleasant my
heart rate is 91 there you go mammalian
diving reflex actually worked and now
I'm gonna move my phone away from the
cold water I'm gonna turn a hot shower
because it's really cold in here
I can now feel the blood coming in from
the extremities because my hands and
feet are absolutely now I'm just gonna
turn on Oh huh